[Music]
because some rules to follow there are
no secrets in the city in New York
there's cameras everywhere phone records
parking tickets
someone saw something heard something
the city always knows
Sam got
shot
like basically best friends
we're gonna find who did this story how
do we figure out who the connection is
Samantha is
we figure out a shower
[Music]
police detectives were here
where were you on July 4th
I don't know how I don't know why
but this girl was connected to us
you might know why she left me I got
shot Sam was one of us whatever Sam knew
I want to know too
[Music]
she left me clues she was on to
something I think I'm the only one that
could figure this out learn more about
these people
they're hiding something
when we started this revolution we knew
it would have a cost
[Music]
all right